- I'm here with Blake Shelton,
and on Skype is Cynthia Nixon!
Give it up for 'em!
(audience cheering)
(laughs) Good, good clap.
Everyone knows,
Blake and I, are a little
competitive. Just a little.
He is. I'm really easy going.
Earlier, (chuckles) he even
gave me a wall of champions,
that displays every person,
who's beat me, at a game, on this show.
Well, I'm not afraid.
I'm gonna give Blake a chance,
to get on that wall, right now.
Keyword meaning chance.
- Yes.
- [Blake] There you go.
- It's a slim one.
And since Blake and I--
- Read it, girl.
- Are both big "Golden Girls" fans,
it's time to play, actually,
"You're Golden GURRRRRL."
(upbeat music)
♪ You're golden gurrrrrl ♪
Cynthia has been kind
enough to volunteer to host,
and probably referee.
Thank you, Cynthia.
Cynthia will read questions
about "The Golden Girls."
The first person to hit the buzzer
and answer correctly gets the point.
You can steal, if the person is wrong.
Most points wins.
But, there's always a little twist,
in the time of COVID, right?
So, since we have to stay
apart from each other,
we're not close enough to hit the buzzer.
So, on his podium, on Blake's
podium, that he gave us.
So, we have these hand extenders,
that I will now showcase, as a baton.
Okay, let's do this.
I had a shot. Let's do this.
First question.
Please, Cynthia.
- Here we go!
- Okay.
- What are,
what are the names,
of all four Golden Girls.
(buzzer rings)
- (yelling) Wait! What? Wait!
- I knew where she was getting at.
- But can't. what do you think?
So we, so you don't have
to say the whole question?
- No. Do you know the names?
Do you know all four names?
- Sophia, Blanche,
(kelly scoffs)
Rose, and Dorothy.
(bell dings)
- I didn't! I didn't know you couldn't.
But! Okay.
- What do ya mean you didn't know?
This is your show, this is--
- I, I didn't, no!
- This is you TV show!
- I don't make up the games.
- [Cynthia] All right.
- I'm not--
- Right here, on T-K-C-S!
- You got one down. Four to go!
- (laughing over announcement) T-K-C-S!
- I thought that you had to
listen the whole question.
Okay. Fine.
- All right, question number two.
- Okay.
- What is
the favorite dessert of the golden girls?
(buzzers ring simultaneously)
- Oh! Oh!
Awe, you got that one I think.
- Blake?
- Cheesecake!
- Yes!
(bell dings)
That is correct!
(audience cheering)
- Dammit!
- All right,
we've got Blake for two.
- He can not get on this wall, Cynthia!
- Okay.
- This is a really hard one.
- Oh, like the last one was simple?
Okay.
- Rose
is originally from what small town?
(laughter in audience)
- Awe, she says it every episode. (sighs)
- I have it.
I'm going to let you struggle
with it for a minute,
but, I do have a hint.
- Okay. I think we need the hint.
- It is also,
the name,
of a snowman,
who likes warm hugs.
(buzzer ringing)
- Olaf Minnesota!
- No! That's not right!
- St. Olaf, but the judges Take it!
- Oh! That's not right!
(bell dinging)
- Yup.
- What's not right?
(audience cheering)
- That is--
- Yeah, yeah.
- That is not close enough, Cynthia.
- What? I--
- This is bull crap!
- I think it is.
- Olaf!
- The judges accept it.
- St. Olaf!
- St. Olaf? But, he, I.
- Hey, anybody can just be Olaf.
- Everybody knows that he's a saint.
- But, if you're a saint
Olaf, that's big deal.
- Everybody knows that he's a saint Olaf.
I don't have to say saint,
you can leave the saint off.
I didn't know. (laughs)
- Okay.
The theme song goes:
" Thank you for being a friend,
traveled down the road and back again."
What is the next line?
(buzzer ringing)
- Oh!
- "Your heart is true,
- Damn!
- "You're a pal and a confidant."
(bell dings)
(audience wooing)
- Damn!
(audience cheering)
You're so quick at the, it's this hand!
I'm saying, I'm saying flag on the play.
- I'm afraid Blake has got three.
- Oh my gosh!
Whatever!
- He's unbeatable.
- I think, that I'm calling--
- I'm afraid that Blake
- I think that this--
- Is going on the Wall,
of Champions.
- I-- (sighs)
- Thank you, Cynthia.
Thank you.
- So, and the winner's Blake!
Watch Ratched, everybody!
- Yes!
Watch it!
- Okay. Do we have a picture
of Blake, for the wall?
Oh God.
- Oh, thank you.
Okay. No, hold on. Let me see it first.
Let me just. Do you have a little?
Can I have a, Oh, that's so interesting.
That just in case--
- How 'bout the Sasquatch?
You done with the Sasquatch?
- Just in case,
the pigs are flying,
and hell is freezing
over, and you beat me,
(audience laughing)
these are...
Okay. here we go.
I put a little tears on your face,
'cause I, I actually let you win,
just so you can be on the wall.
- In your defense, you have been drinking.
- (laughs) I have.
- Yup.